I don't know where you found that but I
am taking it down first of all Steve
Carell owns that's what she said he owns
it yep no thanks I'm good
that's what she said mom my mother's
coming that's what she said no why did
you get it so big
hey that's what she said does the skin
look red and swoon that's what she said
that's my joke
damn it Dwight that's what she said huh
I don't get it
grapes seductive how about the Phyllis
Angela dispute
you already did me that's what she said
Dwight get out of my nook that's what
she said that's what she said that's
what she said I wanna give you something
oh and the future if I want to say
something funny or witty or do an
impression I will no longer ever do any
of those things
does that include that's what she said
mm-hmm yes wow that is really hard you
really think you can go all day long
well you always left me satisfied in
smiling huh that's what she said yeah so
$300 do me the house acts the only gavel
I could find it squeaks when you bang
that's what she said
hey buttercup I am on my way should be
there about 15
yeah that's what she said why is this so
hard that's what she said oh my god
we're sitting in as deep as you can yeah
I'm definitely go along no no I need two
men on this that's what she said no time
but she did no time guys get on this
yeah don't don't make it harder than it
has to be that's Jason
can you make that straighter that's what
she said did you plan that no can you
make that straighter that job looks hard
you should put your mouth on that how
can you even use that one naturally join
up once I find up comes the toolbar
that's what she said what we have to do
your office is full of genitalia oh hey
so is lo que de Jael that's what he says
damn it Oscar would you reach over and
touch his thing that's what he said
right guys cuz of gay I'm glad of today
spurred social change that's part of my
job as regional manager but you know
what even if it didn't at least we put
this matter to bed that's what she said
or he said this is huge that's what she
said I'll be here ten years that's what
I said
that's efficient that's a who's that I
never know I just say it I say stuff
like down you know it's a lighten the
tension when things sort of get hard
that's what she said hey nice so instead
you screwed me she's no listen to me
Mike you got to do something about
though you don't get you need to get
back on top that's what she said yeah
yeah one more bite of you Claire each
hold it in your mouth if you can't
swallow
really nothing and you were directly
under her the entire time that's what
she said
excuse me that's what she said miss
Levinson that she was your direct
superior what why would she say that no
wait I don't understand who's on the
Cygnus with all due respect I'm in the
middle of the line of questioning now
mr. Scott what did you say miss Levinson
said regarding your employment status
with respect to her corporate position
come again
that's what she said I don't know what
you're talking he was just telling a
joke before so can we move on to another
question are you sure yes can you go
back to where this digression began mr.
Schneider and you were directly under
her the entire time mr. Scott that's
what she said
delivery is all wrong butchering it
Michael you were making this harder than
it has to be that's cheesy
no comedy is a place where the mind goes
to tickle a South that's what she said
I'm not saying it won't be hard but we
can make it work that's what she said
all right
Oh
this is gonna feel so good getting this
thing off my chest
I can't be there for you I'm sorry Jim I
just really wish there was something I
could do
is there any mustard hell mustard no
mustard just eat it eat it Phyllis dip
it in the water so it'll slide down your
gullet more easily come on you guys
you